je suis maintenant colonel mansart je
travaille pour la dgse si vous êtes
victoria du dec vous êtes né le 11 août
1989 aux parents s'appelle il ya les
christine vous avez déclaré que dix sept
mille euros de revenus l'année dernière
lors vous en avez gagné le double
pourquoi moi bonsoir oui j'étais dans la
salle à l'instant et je vous ai vu je
vous ai vu danser c'était très beau
tu veux quoi le type qui est venu vous
voir en loge s'appelle salem al jazeera
c'est un trafiquant d'armes
franco-libanais financent des groupes
terroristes partout dans le monde
il avait disparu de nos radars réparé
aujourd'hui à paris savoir c'est cool de
danse ensemble on a besoin de vos
positions sur son téléphone sa siphonne
toutes les informations en une minute
respecte les autres qui se battent pour
leurs femmes il est dangereux
je sais qui tu es
à part toi la gamine de banlieue tu as
failli devenir danseuse étoile je veux
faire quoi ce soir on du shit ou danse
avec moi
qui toi [ __ ]